Venezuela's dictator dances right
outside people suffer a dime it's so
cruel and unnecessary Venezuela should
be rich
not long ago Venezuela was the richest
country in Latin America
it still has greater oil reserves than
Saudi Arabia but today Venezuelans
starve
these people are fighting over bags of
flour and then there's the violence one
Venezuelan is murdered every 20 minutes
so are American celebrities who praised
you go Chavez's People's Revolution now
embarrassed by what they said well they
admit they were wrong leftist
intellectual Noam Chomsky fond over
Chavez said he's made a better world see
how a better world is being created and
can speak to the person who's inspired
it actor Sean Penn met with Chavez and
said this he's done the moment and
incredible things for the 80% of the
people that are very poor their actor
Danny Glover did some playful boxing and
hugging with Chavez that he praised his
vision for Humanity Michael Moore claims
Chavez eliminated 75% of extreme poverty
come on Michael Chavez added to extreme
poverty who is emotion is his director
Oliver Stone made this exhibit film
celebrating Chavez and Latin American
socialism take an incredible look and an
extraordinary benefit of a father he's
talking about that
no they're not now they'd starve and
fear they'll be killed model Naomi
Campbell went to Venezuela and said I'm
amazed to see the love for the social
programs we asked all of them if they
talk about their love of Chavez only one
respondent Noam Chomsky his
anti-capitalist teachings have misled
millions of students but they've worked
for Chomsky after he praised Chavez's
sharp poverty reduction Chavez returned
the favor by holding up Chomsky's book
at the UN that made it a best-seller
so is Chomsky now ashamed of his praise
no he wrote me he said at the time he
praised Chavez Venezuela had seen a
remarkable reduction in poverty he cited
this Harvard magazine article but this
was written by a leftist who helped
write Oliver Stone's movie so I asked
Chomsky given the current crisis in
Venezuela should you now say to the
students who've learned from you
socialism wrecks people's lives Chomsky
wrote me back
I never described Chavez a state
capitalist government as socialist
private capitalism remained capitalists
were free to undermine the economy in
all sorts of ways like massive export of
capital
what capitalists exported capital and
undermined the economy by abandoning
their homes and fleeing across the
border to Colombia thousands of
Venezuelans crossed daily in search of
food medicine and work these people are
socialist fools useful idiots Lenin
would have called them as much as I'd
enjoy rubbing their noses in their
stupidity now I cannot rejoice because I
know Venezuela's descent into chaos will
not be the last time we hear of a dying
socialist economy socialism failed in
all these places we are yet to see one
socialist country succeed and yet sadly
they and other countries refuse to learn
the lessons of history other countries
will give socialism ago useful idiots
will sing socialism's praises until the
last light goes out
you